I don't care you're a bouncer that works
in my club because I'm a stripper I'll
see your face only if you like it though
you want to taste me no do it stay in
the blue box I like it kinky stay in the
blue box Grace don't stay in the blue
box
pulling into Liberty Ford they're
stopping
[Music]
roll down the windows
stop
[Music]
who else is in the car
stop don't get out
I'm asking you questions you answer okay
and I want you to
get you
get on me like that 26 headquarters it's
a female
[Music]
all right step out
a white female put your hands behind
your back
put your hands behind your back
why did you take off like that I'm sorry
drinking or something no
where are you coming from
Broadway
come on
can you stop pulling me like that nope
do you have anything in your pockets oh
yeah oh yeah
touch me real quick
it may feel intervise
all right stop
sitting there no you don't want to stop
are you on something right now no I just
came for dinner with my trip
how much you have to drink there
two doubles of what good child okay
so you are drunk and I'm
where's the owner of that vehicle I
don't know who's Don to smash I just
bought it
all right
another officer is on the way he's gonna
be dealing with the crash I got this OVI
so if you're all right though no injury
[Music]
um are you injured no do you need EMS no
okay I need to talk to you what
don't hit me with a what
what do you need
don't try me because I used to be a
paramedic okay
so hit me with it what you need okay I
know did you want to listen
what is
what's that you want a drug bust
down to two do you have drugs in the car
I don't okay all right you want to check
it we are gonna check it my trick that
vehicle is gonna get towed
so you're gonna give them the clothes
out of it oh yeah we'll get what you
need out of it what is your name stay in
the car stay in the car okay I
understand get in the car all right get
your leg in the car listen handsome man
get your leg in the car
get your foot in the car just stop what
is your name
Grace what
g-r-a-c-e
[Music]
yeah do you know your social
no
all right I'm gonna get your driver's
license out of your purse okay you can
do that all right put your foot in the
car
do I have to yes put your foot in the
car why you gotta be so demanding
why
what's up
she just rear-ended that car 303-71 this
was the flock camera hit I thought he
was taking off from me
15 Franc but she said she could just
pull out the car
do you know who she is no Grace
spoonerman I'm gonna get her license
yeah she doesn't know we're social or
anything
I'm telling you I'm not
trying to that I am but I'm not
none of that even makes sense Claire
confirming she's under 21.
three doubles three doubles yeah
six drinks
that's why it smells like that
where
are you drinking
where's your friend live I really don't
know because I'm not from Ohio yeah
I'm just gonna do hgn
have you had an OVI before what's up
what's that you get out of couch she's
just gonna fight with you yeah
very small it's not like me so hey
um hey do you wanna yeah go ahead do
that okay
what's that my toe the new clothes I
just got
we'll get you what you need out of it in
a minute here in a minute though I'm
gonna run you through some testing all
right you can definitely run with this
and test ing okay that's obviously
swimming
all right
is there anything else in the vehicle
that we should know about
me okay okay
my new clothes that is a dicks
Finish Line
and some like Tupperware okay there's
some black Tupperware in there I got my
steak in there okay with asparagus and
mashed potatoes okay I need that
sorry is someone gonna be able to pick
you up you want someone to pick me up
because I can
yeah we'll see how the testing goes what
is the time
time right now
6 35
call my friend
before
I'm not trying to say hi to your job but
I'm just telling you call my job do you
have insurance for that vehicle
yes
broke ass hoe I think you're drinking
and driving right now
um definitely because Luke is saying a
regular without drinking who can what
now
can't sell Dick without selling it
before it come
what do you mean you understand that no
no no you gotta make it high
before it comes okay did you just move
here from Georgia yes yes okay how long
you been up in Cleveland like
like maybe a year why'd you move up here
because I didn't know it was a snowy and
it's cold what's a good phone number for
you
I don't like talking to you between
These Bars can I talk to you in person
you are talking to me in person no I'm
not
I'm talking to you between bars right
now okay what's your current address
right now where are you staying no don't
worry about it
what's your current well I need your
current address
you need to give me your current address
right now what do you want to do if I
don't I'm gonna charge you with
obstructing
official business what is here
it's cool cares what is your current
address
so I was
speaking
um
whatever you gotta do
just the uh oh three yeah
because I'm not shit I'm not excited to
Cleveland I'm not
Columbus Ohio none of that okay
[Music]
don't worry about that so here's the
thing Grace I don't care if you will
though because if we can't figure out
who you are where you stay at you're you
sit in jail until they fingerprint you
and find it I could do it I don't want
to do that do it what's your current
idea are you staying here
and then it's right out exactly what
happened essentially
heading driving westbound a vehicle okay
yeah I was right behind it when it
happened too I'm so glad you did and I
thought she was comparing yeah and I
scooted over yeah and I was like so
believe it or not
the light we have like license plates
readers in the city yeah there's a
felony warrant attached to this car so I
was looking for it fortunately she
doesn't have it it's somebody else so
but that's what I thought they were
taking off for me because of that sure
but she's a strong
I think hey guess what
your bouncer that works in my club
because I'm a stripper hey Christy No
where's that
where is it like what do you mean where
is it you know don't play dumb with me
okay don't blame me like that okay it's
downtown okay that's fine so at least
seven different offices wanna report me
as fuck because I want to sleep with
them because they work there okay
okay
I don't care
does she just fit on you all right she's
going down we're not gonna test her
yeah
[Music]
nope
all right
she's going down for that yeah
um We're not gonna give her a chance of
time no it's working so she clearly
isn't going to
hold on Grace
with you bro I'm cause you don't believe
me
I don't believe you what do you want I
don't believe you for what I don't
believe
for what
I don't believe you because you wasn't
there to help me when I was needed okay
but I'm telling you
I don't get you but I was bleeding out
where was you was that in Georgia no it
was
we're not in Cleveland right now
we're in Brunswick
you let me leave
barely
barely I have foreign
declare me you let me bleed
you let me bleed
four and a half ounces
of blood you let me bleed out okay on
this side of the streets okay
I don't trust you
you wouldn't say I'm in touch with to
deal with me you can
I don't trust you
you let me bleed okay
I want your blood pumping out my areas
to see you okay no it doesn't no hold on
hold on don't get out of the car getting
out of the car I'm telling you okay you
don't know what the fuck you're dealing
with okay you don't okay
you no not okay fuck hey
you don't
you don't know what you're doing with
you don't know how many
girls
have been captured to take to Atlanta
Atlanta Ohio is the way to go Atlanta
Georgia yes
you're gonna get through
and I promise that
I promise that I don't care about you
let me go
I really don't give a fuck
all right we're gonna read her I want
you to capture the girls that are in
danger
stop I want you to capture the girls
that are in danger
are you gonna understand that
are you gonna capture the Americans that
are in danger
no just the man I'm gonna tell you
straight up
can I step up we're gonna go back to the
station so you can I step up and talk to
him no you gotta stay in the car right
now woman a woman no I can't step up and
step back in no
no you're in the car trust me
you don't trust me stay in the car come
on you don't
know please stay in the car you don't
trust me go ahead pull it you don't
trust me
[Music]
don't trust me
you don't trust me you don't trust me
you just spit on me yeah I did because
you know
[Music]
ready
this is why our country don't get no
justice
okay so he'll probably end up going
we'll just we'll just commit her on the
OVI the M1
the obstruction of yours
can be short form right
my recommendation is do the OVI up into
on traffic with other act site yeah and
do the obstructing on the long form
everything in the muni yep yep and then
both handle everything tomorrow Monday
Monday court date or Wednesday
five days I think one's two Wednesday
okay
[Music]
so you like your job yeah it's not bad
you like your job it's not bad yeah you
get paid
no right into this no exactly
cause I'll bring my thumb right now to
get off these cups stop playing
well you're gonna be out soon so don't
do that
I'll kill your face only if you like it
though that's all the questions
what
what's up
let me off bro let me off where they
torture me bitch I read they beat
choices in there with you
by the Mexicans
the Mexican cartel
Ira because you didn't buy them things
to do with you
wouldn't let me go step out no you
wouldn't let me go I couldn't hold it
okay
no shoes
all right
I couldn't hold it
there were 22 please
what's your name Logan you look like a
low
[Music]
God
you don't let me keep pissing no come on
I don't want to piss you come on okay
shit bye
hold on
[Music]
door 23.
I have a bacterial infection okay just
stand in that blue box okay just stay in
that blue box whatever
can't take it off no leave it on leave
it on
Grace just stop
I'm gonna eat a female leg here we'll
get it
just stay there
stay there okay
stay in the blue box
you want to taste me no do it stay in
the blue box I like it kinky stay in the
blue box Grace don't stay in the blue
box
step back
you can step back you touch me
[Music]
stay in that blue box look no no yes
[Applause]
[Music]
stay in the blue box
just stay there
[Applause]
you didn't catch me and you didn't catch
them you go let people slice and dice
your community before you let them
connect the pieces stay in the blue box
don't touch me she no I don't need
[Music]
disrespect him fuck all right
now
all right
over here do you not understand yeah I'm
saying I got you I got it I'm saying I
understand
right I understand you wanted to say
that I got it bitch I mean
right I got you no 23. no you don't no
you don't bro
hey hey come stand right here at this
window
stay right here
[Music]
[Applause]
watch out for all that here
quiet and get in the car
no we're not don't kick don't kick don't
kick don't kick
[Music]
you got gloves
what's your shoes
you can't come in here acting them I
don't care you don't give a fuck the way
I was bleeding out the side of my leg
I had two pints of blood left to my soul
you ain't give a fuck neither of y'all
okay
you don't have to grab me just making
sure you go okay grab me I don't care
[Music]
thank you
Grace relax you I'm not gonna relax
we'll tell us where to go dear no you
can't just run through here because I
ran through here when I had it I put my
fucking laying on my motherfucking legs
what Grace Grace Grace
no I can't
what's wrong
take a minute indoor voice I'm right
here what's wrong no
no
no no
so you're gonna hit me off
[Music]
please stop
funny bro
no I wasn't even no you was good
stop
you wasn't giggling
you want to give me what a person in
this bitch
put me in a room bro